die jüngste entdeckung macht hoffnung
auf die besiedlung des mondes das bisher
nicht gelöste problem wasser jetzt
wurden lover höhlen entdeckt die zum
einen für eine mondstation perfekt
liegen und zur anderen wassereis
enthalten könnten
wie ist die lage auf dem mond jetzt bei
klicks und science fiction herzlich
willkommen
es ist eine der größten
herausforderungen für eine mondstation
wie kommen die bewohner innen an wasser
von der erde zum mond transportieren
würde unsummen kosten es muss in jedem
fall dort gewonnen werden und wasser
wurde ja schon auf dem mond gefunden
allerdings ist es in reguliert gebunden
in diesem gestein reagieren die protonen
des sonnenwindes mit dem enthaltenen
sauerstoff und es entsteht wasser das
allerdings nur in kleinen mengen
existiert und schwer abzubauen ist und
auch das mondgestein enthält wasser in
homöopathischen dosen also minimal in
schmelz einschlüssen aus der zeit als
der mond noch vulkanisch aktiv war ist
neben anderen mineralien auch wasser
eingeschlossen auch nur sehr schwer zu
gewinnen mit den jetzt entdeckten höhen
könnte dieses problem gelöst seien bei
der auswertung von aufnahmen der nasa
raumsonde luna rekord von peter lro hat
ein forschungsteam jetzt lover höhlen
entdeckt die möglicherweise wassereis
enthalten die höhen liegen im viel öl
austrat er erst rund 70 kilometer groß
und liegt auf 72 grad nördlicher breite
des mondes rillen in der dicken
laubschicht des kraters deuten auf lover
hüllen hin würden diese höhlen jetzt eis
enthalten wären sie perfekt für eine
mondstation geeignet sie böten schutz
und wasser zitat ich denke ich könnte
einen wirklich spannenden ort für die
erkundung und möglicherweise sogar eine
menschliche kolonie gefunden haben
das sagt pascal i vom ames research
center der nasa und vom seti institute
in katar hat sein team jetzt öffnungen
entdeckt die zwischen zehn und 30 metern
groß sind und auch etwas macht die lage
erhöhen zum einen extrem interessant und
zum anderen die wahrscheinlichkeit für
eis sehr hoch sie sind 550 kilometer vom
nordpol des mondes entfernt und liegen
auf der der erde zugewandten seite mit
ausreichend sonnenlicht zitat damit ist
der krater außerhalb der dauerhaft
beschatteten gebiete der lunaren
polargebieten das erklärt die damit kann
dort einfach strom aus sonnenlicht
hergestellt werden die höhlen werden
wahrscheinlich aber auch kalt genug um 1
zu enthalten wie eisel hier auf der erde
und im gegensatz zu dem im mondgestein
alles viel leichter abzubauen die lage
ermöglicht zudem die einfache
kommunikation mit der erde weil die höhe
neben der erde zugewandt sind zitat
diese entdeckung ist aufregend und kommt
gerade zur rechten zeit gerade wenn wir
uns auf eine rückkehr des menschen zum
mond vorbereiten so der präsident des
goethe-instituts bild diamond jetzt
müssen diese höhlen zunächst unbekannt
erforscht werden um zu klären wie groß
sie sind und ob sie wasser enthalten
sobald es neues dazu gibt erfahrt ihr es
natürlich hier wenn er kein video dazu
und auch zu allen anderen themen
verpassen wollt dann tut mir ein abo
aufsaugen vergesst nicht den genau auf
die glocke nur dann manipulierte
algorithmus von youtube nicht die
benachrichtigung über neue videos und
erfahrt auch wirklich dass ein neues
video online gegangen ist hier also hier
geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken
wasser auf den montag geht es um die
funde von wasser im mondgestein
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran